Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Anything else would
like to be,
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue interstellar.
This episode is brought to you by movement watches and that is spelled M v m t
movement watches.
I first became aware of this company back in 2014 when there are brand,
brand new,
maybe company because they won first place in Shopify as build a business
competition.
The founders are two college dropouts who wanted to wear fancy watches but had
one wee little problem.
They couldn't afford fancy watches so they decided to scratch their own itch.
Since then,
they're high quality.
Affordable watches have gone from startup to more than 1 million watches sold
across 160 countries.
It's an awesome success story and when you check out the product,
you'll know why they offer classic design,
quality construction and many different modern styles.
So you can really pick one that suits you.
You might want to start one.
I would suggest probably appeal to a lot of folks out there is the classic black
silver,
so search classic black silver.
The guys that movement have a great offer for listeners of this podcast.
They're offering 15% off your entire purchase with free shipping and free
returns.
If you're dissatisfied for any reason and they are very,
very famous for their customer support,
just visit movement,
watches.com forward slash Tim that's M v empty watches.com forward slash.
Tim
This podcast is brought to you by Mizzen and main.
Many of you long time listeners know how I feel about Mizzen and main.
They make the most comfortable dress shirts in the world.
Quite possibly they use advanced performance fabrics,
which provides stretch and comfort,
but that's not the real selling point to me.
That's all great.
It's all really good,
but they are the only dress shirts so to speak,
that I travel with because you don't have to iron them no more steaming,
no more headache.
I can just bunch them up and throw them in a bag,
pull them out and no one will be the wiser.
They're fancy enough for important dinners,
but made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So they're all purpose.
And hundreds of pro athletes love these shirts,
including NFL,
all pro JJ watt.
And last time these guys were on the show.
They sold out of every item.
They feature every single skew.
So if you're interested in getting a shirt,
you might want to check them out on the faster side.
Just go to tim.blog four slash shirts and you can receive $50 off when you
purchase three or more shirts.
So check it out.
tim.blog forward slash shirts.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode,
the Tim Ferriss Show where it is my job to deconstruct world class performers of
all different types,
whether they come from the worlds of business,
chess,
military,
sports,
you name it.
In this case poker.
This episode of the podcast features Phil Hellmuth at Phil underscore,
Helmuth,
h.
E l,
who has one more word,
who is why I'm all whoa.
To each have polka world series of poker bracelets than any other person in
history.
I'm not drunk.
I'm high on life.
This interview comes from my television show,
fearless fear and in parenthesis less because the objective is to learn to fear
less,
not be fearless in which I interviewed world class performers on stage about how
they've overcome doubt,
conquered fear,
and made their toughest decisions.
You can watch the entire first episode with illusionists David Blaine for
free@att.net forward slash fearless so you can check that out and to watch all
episodes,
just visit direct tv.com or check out your account under ACTV,
so directv.com that is with one t d I r e c t v.com.
We recorded about three hours of material when Phil and I sat down and only one
hour was used for the TV show.
That means this podcast is almost entirely new content that did not appear in
the television episode.
In this conversation,
we explore many things including Phil's morning routine,
the importance of goals and blessings,
how he became the youngest person to win the world series of poker,
his prep for the high stakes games in which he plays what it takes to compete at
the highest level and much,
much more.
Also,
since we recorded the show,
Phil published his autobiography,
Poker Brat,
well titled,
you can check that out.
So with all of that said,
please enjoy this wide ranging conversation with Phil Hellmuth and let's get
started,
right?
Meow,
enjoy.
I'm your host,
Tim Ferris.
And on this stage will be deconstructing world class performers of all types to
uncover and distill the specific tactics they've used to overcome doubt,
tackle their hardest decisions,
and ultimately succeed on their own terms.
So let's do a show of hands.
How many people here think they can tell when someone is lying?
50% now,
how many of you think you can lie and not get caught?
30 how many of you who raised your hands?
It'd be willing to bet your entire life savings on being able to do that?
All right.
It's six or seven.
Well,
for the last 30 years.
My guest tonight has made his living reading behavior,
analyzing the odds and gambling for his future.
In 1989 he became the youngest main event champion at the world series of poker
and he holds the world record for most of it.
Winds at 14 and he's still going.
Please welcome author,
entrepreneur and professional player,
Phil Hellmuth.
[inaudible]
I can always tell it,
I have a lot of friends who watch poker and I'm an avid sand but not a competent
player.
So we're not going to be at the same table anytime and less than a spectator.
Uh,
but I can always tell when you're on because of the beeping it's in.
Draws me into the room.
The good news is this isn't really a family programming,
so no beliefs,
uh,
in this conversation if the,
if it all comes out.
I want to talk a little bit about the scrappy.
You're trying to encourage me to swear.
You know,
this is my,
I'm from Long Island.
It might come out on my part.
I do drop f bombs if I get wound up.
So,
uh,
yeah I guess that's light nudge but swearing swearing's part of the lexicon now
and things have changed so much,
you know,
um,
and so I do probably swear more than I should even want them on the microphone
doing events,
you know,
and someone will be like,
there's always one or two people of the couple of hundred at the event,
they're offended.
They usually don't say anything.
That's pretty good.
I mean that's pretty,
pretty good percentage.
I mean that's when
like I have a goal sheet on my mirror and I have a blessing sheet on my mirror.
So at the morning when I'm brushing my teeth and not paying attention,
I see what my lifetime goals are,
what are my goals for that year.
And then I also see my blessings.
So I leave hopefully happy cause I've seen the blessings and focus cause I know
what my goals are.
So for me that's,
you know,
somebody
[inaudible]
so let me just wrap this up cause this kind of fun.
So the other day,
all the time in the world
is at Starbucks three or four months ago.
And someone came up to me and I was really tired.
It was a Sunday morning and I had slept well and someone came up to me that
doesn't know me that well or whatever,
but I'm polite and I smiled and I shook his hand or whatever and just wanted to
get my coffee and get out of there.
And then his wife pops up and she's just glowing and she's like,
Phil,
I got to tell you,
I was at your speech.
I put my goals up on my mirror and I accomplish them with within two months.
And she was glowing.
And I thought,
wow,
I had a profound influence on her life and it just made me feel,
I gave me,
I know as a professional poker player at the top of the game,
I do things no one else does in the game.
And I know that I'm motivated.
I've known,
I've known this since maybe 2002,
um,
where,
where someone came up to me and they said,
Phil,
I was in a coma and I,
and I woke up,
cause I imagine playing you heads up at poker.
And this guy sat down in the audience when I was playing heads up for a world
championship and my wife said,
he sat down and you want 11 hands in a row.
And she said,
there's something weird.
And so from that moment on,
way back in 2002,
I realized that I'm motivating,
you know,
that I'm inspirational to people,
not the stuff that you see on television,
although that's kind of fun to watch me beeping and whatever.
But me performing at the top of what I do,
you know,
I mean,
you watch some great athletes do things no other great athletes can do.
I liked watching tiger woods in his prime.
I like watching Michael Jordan.
Now I'm not as big as those guys,
but in my industry I,
it's kind of fun to see,
wow,
how did Phil know that to fold this or move in with this?
And so,
yeah,
I think,
I think when your,
uh,
when I'm achieving the most I can achieve and I'm playing poker like no one else
has ever seen,
I think that that can be inspirational for,
you know,
millions of people that watch it.
So we,
in that period when you were struggling,
did you have any particular coping mechanisms or strategies that you use,
things to occupy your time that helped you get through that?
Absolutely big coping mechanism for me.
And this applied itself in poker too,
because when you're young in poker,
you're usually reckless.
So I told you I won the main event,
$750,000 for first,
right?
This is 1989 men.
So,
you know,
and I'd been taking way too many chances.
And uh,
and so at that point from there,
yes,
I was smart.
I bought a penthouse condominium,
you know,
and paid cash for it.
Yes.
I put aside money for taxes,
but the other $300,000 I lost.
So yeah,
I ended up with,
and I mean we have bought a couple cars,
so beautiful cars,
penthouse condominium,
but I'm struggling to pay $800 a month.
Condo fees.
Yeah,
it's like a year later,
and so the coping mechanism there is rather than,
it's not that I'm avoiding the present,
it's that you're like,
this is a moment where there's a lot of rain.
So number one,
I'm going to develop strategies for the next time I have money.
My money management system has to be really solid and I have to actually apply
it and use it.
That's number one.
Number two,
I would,
I would look forward and I'd say,
all right,
what does it look like in two years?
It looks amazing in two years,
and so in the depths of dealing with some of the worst times,
I would take advantage of that down period of that being trodden down to be more
focused.
All right,
how did this happen?
How can I play poker better?
How can I meant money management,
money management is more important than playing poker or poker players.
Just,
Oh yeah,
we can ask me about that later.
But that's very interesting topic.
But to go with it,
you know,
so that that was,
those are the,
those are the kinds of the things I would use.
Vince Vaughn,
I was talking about this last night,
you know,
he,
he taught me,
he taught me something that I hadn't thought about much.
When someone's looking at a flop,
they usually haven't hit it.
They're trying to figure out do I have anything,
the flop meaning when the dealer,
when the first three cards come out,
yes.
But you have to pay attention to all of that.
Tells a story we have.
And then when the next card they'll look at it for a long time to try to figure
out what to make of their hand.
Whereas if they look at it quickly then either have nothing or we were talking
about potentially a strong position.
That was a great observation.
And his part made me realize how smart he is.
Increased my respect factor for him cause he,
cause he got it and pointed out something that I hadn't been paying attention to
recently.
But everything adds up.
It's a picture,
you know,
and,
and how much are they betting and,
and when the next card comes off,
now there's four in the middle.
How much are they betting?
And when the fifth card comes up,
how much are they betting?
Are they hesitating because they think I have to bluff all in here and I have to
man up to do it.
And then when they bluffed it,
they put it in the right away or do they wait?
You know,
and then people try to use things to throw you off so you have to decipher the
whole picture.
So I trust my instincts and when I'm on I look,
I look great.
Yeah.
But I'm just not on every day.
So,
you know,
we filmed so much poker.
Yeah.
There's days where I'm off and then a million of the kids watch it and they say,
fill sucks at poker.
Phil.
Sucks at poker.
Phil sucks at poker.
I hear that.
I've heard that so often in my life.
Um,
that I'm not good at poker.
It's crazy to me.
It's because they watch my worst moments.
And I think I wonder if I watched this guy who was criticizing me for watched
all of his worst moments,
you know,
the blooper reel for somebody else,
Bro.
Deep.
And so you were talking about when you're at your best,
and by the way that can get to me people,
you know,
I mean,
people were telling me I wasn't good at poker.
Coming into the game had passed me by coming into 2010.
Um,
uh,
I sucked at poker,
you know,
uh,
because I hadn't done anything in a couple of years and I mean,
Internet forms filled with how bad I was at poker because I'm a big target and
because I hadn't done anything lately.
And that's fair criticism.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden,
2011 came and I had,
you know,
three second place finishes and everybody's like,
wow.
And in 2012 came and I won two bracelets and everybody's like,
oh my God.
But I swear I'll never forget this 2011,
um,
they were talking about how I was like I'd fallen out of the top 500 poker,
how I sucked at the game.
Exactly.
Three weeks later I had to second place finishes and they were talking about how
it's the greatest
and that was just like,
all right,
what changed?
I mean I was given some advice early on when I was,
when I was writing because I was getting really thrown for a loop with
criticisms.
I remember the first time I got a negative Amazon review the very first time you
out and,
and I wrote this really logic,
a logical,
compassionate reply this like long,
I spent hours on this thing and the carpet.
I was like,
yeah,
go fuck yourself.
And I was like,
ah,
the humanity,
why won't you listen Internet?
And uh,
somebody said to me,
you're never as bad as they say you are and you're never as good as they say you
are either.
And I was like,
all right,
let's put,
did you then stop reading reviews?
I stopped reading most of them on Amazon and Youtube in a few places where it's
like always devolves to like Hitler after like two pages.
Like how did we get to Hitler?
Like it's a kitten video,
but the uh,
what I wanted to ask you before I get too far away,
so you just kind of gave up.
Like I stopped looking at poker forums,
I thousand one.
Yeah,
I just stopped looking.
Yeah.
Well I think it's like you don't,
you,
it's,
there's,
there's how to deal with something and then there's choosing not to like
strategically choosing not to deal with it.
So sometimes it's easier to not go where it's slippery if you don't want to
slip.
Right.
So it's just like with temptation with a quality problem,
but like beautiful,
smart women kind of swarming around when you're in Vegas or something like that.
Similarly,
it's like,
well,
I don't want to have to waste the energy to manage my response to something that
isn't going to be productive anyway because the good stuff is just going to make
my head inflate and the bad stuff isn't going to be probably even accurate or
it's gonna make me feel terrible.
It's like,
what's the outcome that I'm looking for?
But what I wanted to ask you,
because we all my whole life to stay with that a second life has been,
you know,
I would get too inflated by the good stuff.
My ego gets all pumped up.
Yeah.
Now you get to devastated by the bad stuff.
You know what I mean?
And,
and I look back and I was very defensive in a lot of the videos that you may or
may not show,
but a lot of these videos of super defensive until 2011 2012 and I'm like,
wait a minute,
I'm the all time champion.
I have all the records.
Why am I so defensive?
And I think that's part of that defensiveness that that's part of maybe ties in.
I want to be,
I want to be great and I want everybody to think I'm great at Games,
specifically poker.
And uh,
and I think that might may drive me.
Um,
I'm trying to get away from being defensive.
It's tough.
I'm pretty defensive too.
I mean,
I remember I read a tweet today and I was like,
what?
Oh,
Twitter,
I'm,
or Stephen Fry opted out of well known comedian actor of being on Twitter.
And he said,
it's like too many people have peed in the pool.
He's like,
I'm out of here.
They're going to break from Pitt.
From Twitter.
Yeah.
Grass.
But useful metaphor.
Anyway,
I want to talk about,
uh,
one of the times,
maybe you weren't at your best.
You've lost all this money.
Just to go back to where we
were in your timeline,
and I'd read about you setting and number of goals maybe in a taxi cab.
Am I making this up?
Uh,
there were a few goals.
One was world series of poker,
I believe.
Uh,
if this is fiction,
let me know.
Second was uptight.
I've got it.
I've got it from here.
Yeah.
So,
so,
I mean,
this,
this was probably,
I was 21,
I guess,
maybe 22,
something like that.
And,
um,
and I had this kind of like one of these weird touchpoints where something
amazing happens to me.
Weird,
right?
So I'm playing poker and Madison,
Wisconsin,
I wake up and it's foggy and it's,
you know,
and there's snow on the ground and I'm like,
and I'm looking at a two and $4 limit game,
but I have $20,000.
You go to the game,
you might make 200 bucks,
right?
Yeah.
So,
but why do I,
what's,
what am I doing?
You know?
And so I go over there and I'm bored and I don't want to,
and there's no golf course is open and I can't find anything kind of fun to do.
And so two of the guys from the game,
I say,
Hey,
let's go have a drink.
So I've never been a big drug guy,
but I smoked pot.
And then we go to the bar and I'm having a drink and they're playing pool for 10
or $20 a game.
And it's like one in the afternoon.
Yeah.
And I've,
and I'm having a drink and I've smoked pot and I'm suddenly like in there
arguing about $20 at the pool table.
And I'm like,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
You know?
And I'm like,
I gotta get Outta here.
Yeah.
So I go and I,
and I'll never forget,
I opened this door,
right?
And Boom,
like the sun is out now and it's bouncing off the snow and it's just like,
it's like a metaphor for what happened at that moment was the reality of what
happened at that moment.
I opened the door and I saw all the light,
right?
Just,
and it's coming at me and it's bouncing off everything.
And I've been in some dingy bar and I'm just like,
wow,
what is this?
And I call for a taxi.
I would never drive when I'm doing something silly like that,
I get back to my apartment and I'm like,
what are you doing with your life?
And the first thing I do,
I have all this positive momentum and all this energy and I'm like,
this is my lifetime goals.
I'm going to win the main event,
the world series of poker.
If Andre Poker player,
I'm going to be the best in the world.
I'm going to meet and marry an amazing woman.
I'm going to buy a beautiful house.
I'm going to buy a beautiful car and maybe one or two.
So I'm going to write a New York Times bestselling book,
right?
So I said,
these are my lifetime goals,
like six of them,
and then add all this positive momentum and all this energy.
And I'm like,
wow,
I in order to get there,
how am I going to do it?
Well,
I think of it as a pyramid.
First I have to be able to not smoke pot,
not become an alcoholic.
Um,
manage my money,
all these little things on the bottom row of the pyramid.
And then there's the next row of the pyramid exercise,
eating healthy,
all of this stuff.
And the next year I'll make sure that you're studying the game all the way to
the top.
So I designed a pyramid in that moment,
just as creative breakthrough I'm having,
right?
And,
and then I'm like,
well actually I love the concept of a pyramid.
And in poker the money flows up.
So I designed that pyramid.
In that moment I'm just writing for hours,
like a mad man.
And at the bottom of the pyramid is like all the small stakes games that might
happen at a bar.
And then all the home games,
and then some of the Games in Vegas and some of the big games in La,
all the money flows up.
All the people that have success here come to this level.
They dump off the money or they go up most dump off the money.
So the money flows all the way up.
So if I want to be,
if I want to win millions or Deca millions playing poker,
I have to be up here at the top as a player.
And I have to use this pyramid and make sure that I check all the boxes on all
these blocks to get there.
Right.
And I came up with the concept,
I'm overwhelming people.
No,
I have two pyramids and a lifetime goal list.
And then I decided it's important to have something on my bathroom mirror,
which we talked about a little bit already.
And so that concept came that day.
So all of this amazing positive momentum.
But to me that was one of the most,
uh,
I'm calling that in my autobiography,
Poker Brat.
I'm saying that chapter's called.
I can see the light and I just talk about that.
And then I'm devising all these money management strategies.
So what were some of your,
that was a profound moment for me in my life.
What were some of your,
because this is,
this is I think a really critical component as you alluded to earlier.
What were some of those money management strategies before?
Before we,
I'll come to that.
But before I say the amazing thing was with all those goals,
all those little holes I looked like a year later my wife found the list and
maybe two years later and I had knocked off five of those lifetime goals
already.
I'd won the main event.
I'd met Kathy.
You know,
I bought this beautiful condominium.
I,
you know,
I bought some beautiful cars and so just,
it was amazing how many boxes I checked.
Now,
the bestselling book,
I didn't know this and Oh four when I put out play poker,
like the pros,
I didn't know that this would be the one.
I just saw the poker wave coming and I put a how to book out there.
Wrote up myself.
We talked about this last night.
It took two months,
1500 words a day.
Put it out there.
Some guy holds it up on ESPN.
He'd played a seven card,
low tournament,
seven card loke.
What'd he never played before?
What does that mean?
What's a seven card?
Low term?
Uh,
so I mean,
basically the world series of poker as a seven card stud tournament to hold 'em
tournament,
Omaha,
all these different variations of poker.
So he's playing in a seven card though.
He said,
I read Phil Home Use Book and he holds it up,
holds it up on ESPN.
I read Phil,
have you split?
Can I cash for $17,000 not a million.
Not 2 million.
$17,000.
Boom.
My book hits the best seller list.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
It's
a lifetime Dole.
Sorry.
I remember Harper Collins calls me.
They somehow,
I guess we had cell phones by then.
So yeah,
so they,
they called me and they said,
yeah,
where are you staying?
And I'm like,
I'm at the,
I'm at the Loews Hotel.
And they said,
okay,
your book just hit the New York Times bestseller list.
We just sent a bottle of dom tier room.
And I'm like,
and it was a how to list.
So I just walked around high for weeks because that was one of the last goals
that I had to accomplish.
Yeah,
yeah.
And there's so many directions we could go,
but I'm going to go back to the wealth money management.
Yes sir.
So at that time,
because this is,
this is a critical survival skills,
it seems like,
I mean,
foundational for I'm,
he came back to this because I think the people out there should know this.
What's more important?
Great poker skills are great money management,
money management.
And I'll tell you why.
If you have a guy that has poker skills,
let's do a diagram here.
Poker skills of sick of 80 let's say poker skills of 90 okay?
And you have a guy of poker skills of 80 but the guy with 80 manages money
better.
He's going to have a much more comfortable life.
He's going to win as money.
He's going to sit down in the smart games at the right time with the right
amount of money,
and he's just going to flow along.
He's going to pay all of his bills.
It's gonna look boring.
Some of the outside was going to say,
Oh,
you're too conservative.
But meanwhile,
look at the guy who was 90 all right,
but no money management skills loses all his money in one night.
Yup.
Now he has to borrow money from us.
Friends loses that too.
Then he gets staked,
right?
That means someone who's bankrolling,
someone banks rolls him,
but he has so much skill that he hits for 500,000 a tournament.
Okay,
but his back or gets 250,000 but still now we as 250,000 now he's back in
action.
You know when he has a couple of successful months runs up to 400,000 but then
over a series of two weeks loses the whole 400,000 barrels from all of his
friends again because he paid him back last time.
This time he borrows more,
get sticked again.
That's in case you can't pay his bills.
That's a miserable,
that's a tough existence.
And so that's why money is more important than poker skills.
Now,
how specifically by running,
I remember I remember a story where my wife thought I was a madman.
He was a 1997 she thought it was.
I'm wondering how many stories you have,
like uh,
but let's,
let's,
let's start with this one.
So
we're saying as soon as I'm worth $1 million,
I'm going to get staked.
That meant based on what my house was worth on stocks,
all the stuff that I had in my life.
And so I determined I hit the million dollar mark.
This is in asset.
Yeah.
And assets.
Call it 1997 and I was on the way down and I was like,
all right,
I'm getting staked.
I'm going to have ted for stake me.
You know,
cause people were lining up to stake me.
I had pretty good results and so I'm going to have ted Forrest stake me and I
was celebrating honey I'm getting staked by,
wasn't celebrating the fact that I was getting staked.
I was celebrating the fact that I could hit $1 million in net worth and get
staked.
No one in history had done that to that point that I have ever heard of.
Everybody else would go a,
let's get $200,000 from the house.
Let's sell a car,
let's sell some stocks.
Not me.
So I was celebrating in my wife.
I just remember in a hotel in San Francisco,
I was all like,
yes,
you know,
and my wife just was staring at me like with daggers,
like,
what's wrong with you?
You're getting staked and you're celebrating.
But that wasn't it.
The point was I was going to draw this line in the sand and I did it and I got
staked for the next three or four or five years until 2001 and,
and Ted and Ted Forrest was great.
Like,
uh,
like he,
like if I had money,
do,
if I have,
my bills were a lot less than if I had 5,000 a month in bills or 7,000 or
whatever it was.
He would just like press a button and send me the money that was getting staked.
And I had no worries.
I played less.
I spent more time with my family at that point.
And then all of a sudden,
2001 I won 500,000 and tournament's quickly and Ted was entitled to like 400 of
it.
Maybe I want,
yeah,
400 over it or whatever.
And I was more than happy.
You know,
he had faith in me and he made a bunch of money because of me and that was
great.
Um,
but that's what discipline it takes to have great money management.
And now today I have a system where only risk $10,000 a day.
Um,
I'm playing,
you have to look at the percentage.
I look at the percentage,
look at the percentage,
10 thousands not lot risk,
$10,000 a day.
No,
the percentage.
I'm proud of that because actually if I could translate to people at home,
I don't know what that would be for someone at home.
Take a guess.
I mean,
I,
I've done,
I have to take a guess that your net worth,
I don't know.
I forget net worth liquid assets.
Yeah,
I would say it,
it's something that you can comfortably lose and not have it materially
affected.
Do you?
Correct.
And,
and I just figured.
And so for me that was a big step implemented this five years ago and,
and it's been super successful for me because 10,000 doesn't last too long in
the games I play in.
Right.
But I can't always tell when I've lost 10 whether I'm,
the reason I implemented it,
I can't always tell if I'm playing poorly or if I'm just getting unlucky.
There's always,
there's always mystery there,
mystery surrounding how good your playing.
And so I just decided to,
like,
for me it's been a great system and if I lose it,
I'm like,
all right,
I can't do anything.
I can't play for 24 hours or whatever until I wake up.
All right,
well I might as well go to the movie.
I might sleep a couple of times,
couple of shifts,
watch some movies in the room,
chill and show up fresh the next day.
And,
and there's,
I don't want to lose 10 today.
I just did it yesterday.
So you come up like ready to play and you've thought about did I do everything
right?
So,
I mean that's,
that's been a good system for me for the last five or six years.
How would you have reacted had you not one?
I think it would have been devastating.
Um,
but I would have still had 350 400,000 you have to understand at that point I
was already,
there were four majors per year and then there were like nine world series that
year.
They were saying 11 world series of poker championships.
And then there were like three other ones who really wanted to win,
which I considered majors.
And one of them was the bicycle club main event and I won that one in 1988 in
August.
So I had already won one of the majors and was all over the poker press.
And so to win that was just kind of like,
you know,
that that was the greatest moment,
maybe the greatest moment in my poker career just to win that.
It's nice to back it up
13 more times.
This,
speaking of backing it up at what point before 1989.
So I know we're doing a little memento style,
like chronologically fragmented approach here,
but bear with me the,
I don't know why I keep looking at you.
You look very pensive.
Uh,
the question was,
which I appreciate.
It's like thinking hard.
I the,
uh,
the question is,
when did Johnny show you his hand?
This is what I've read.
Maybe this is also just myth and you saw something
or at least you told him he's answering hand the answering thing about this.
This is more for poker people.
I'll try to,
I'll try to make it so everybody can understand.
So the blinds were five and 10,000 whenever heads up.
And first thing I had whispered to Johnny Chan,
we played 32 men side whispered at the beginning.
You're going to have to play perfect and get lucky to beat me.
Now,
if the cameras that have been working in those days,
um,
that,
that's one that have been played a lot and people would have said,
boy,
that kids cocky,
but I wish we were to just search.
Chan could here and exactly forehands before I had had the ace seven of
diamonds,
I still remember and I opened for 35,000 so you have to think in terms of how
much money you're raising.
Okay,
so that's three and a half times the big blind.
That's how they look at it.
These days at 3.5 is pretty big,
but then sham called the 35 and raised 130,000 more,
almost twice the size of the pot.
These are unheard of.
Big numbers and a mental note went off.
I said,
I'm not going to play with them this hand,
but he's stepping on the aggression.
Now I can see he's putting a lot of money.
He's become very aggressive.
I'm going to fold this.
I don't like folding it because everybody else in the world back then would put
a lot of money in with an any ace,
especially a seven suited said,
I'm going to fold this,
but I noticed he's changed.
His style in my mind was just completely encompassed and how am I going to win
this?
Exactly.
Forehands later I looked at two black nines and it was like the script was
already written.
I'm going to open for 35,000 he's going to raise 130,000 and I'm going to just
pile and 700,000 just boom that quick.
And so it was like,
sometimes scripts are written from hands.
And so I did that.
He did it.
I waited.
I didn't want to give anything away.
I didn't want to show any excitement,
didn't want to do anything that would change him from doing what he was going to
do.
He reraise hundred 30,000 the minute those chips hit the pot,
I said,
I'm all in.
That's like he started the hand with 600,000 boom,
I'm raising all your chips right back on you.
And um,
and it was two black knight's a pretty strong hand.
And now he started studying and thinking.
And I thought to myself,
if he had ace king or Ace Queen or Ace Jack or Ace 10 he would have put the
money in already.
And those hands are very close.
Like maybe I'm a 12 to 10 13 to 10 favorite.
I don't want to play a pot where I'm only 12 to 10 or 13 to 10 I don't want to
leave it to chance.
I also thought that he would call with any pair above tens instantly.
So at that point I'm thinking,
wow,
what does he have?
Do I want them to call or not?
And I'd been around poker long enough where I didn't want to influence the
action by saying by acting strong or acting weak.
I said just let things play out and see where it lands.
But if he had king queen,
I didn't want him to call him only a small favorite.
What do you had the ace seven of spades.
I was Kinda surprised.
Also he would have called right away with eights or sevens,
which is a great position for me.
When he had ace seven of spades,
I was Kinda surprised it was a little weaker and I think he decided this kid is
tough.
He and I had faced off in the 1988 world series he'd seen me.
We'd faced off in August at the tournament I won when I won the major at the
bicycle club that I just mentioned and so he knew that was there.
He'd even come out in Esquire magazine in January and said,
this kid is going to win the main event.
As soon as he learns to Tuck it in a little bit.
That was more fuel for my fire.
Reading myself in Esquire magazine.
That was a big thing man.
Back then,
you know,
I mean nobody talked about poker and so I just I and so when he called with a
seven of spades,
I was kind of surprised,
but again,
I thought already going to find a way to outdraw me.
I mean it's just like,
it's not that I felt the negativity,
it's more like you have to be prepared for him to hit it.
He's been lucky.
You've watched them get lucky and so I mean when that six of spades hit,
I was,
you know,
most are lear heaven.
I was going to tell you about the question that Antonio asks me that I told you
about last night.
Let's this jump into,
okay,
now the subjects which fulfill,
get used to it.
Antonio is a mutual friend,
very,
very savvy investor and entrepreneur doesn't,
we can say his last name,
right?
Sure.
Antonio,
Gracias.
Antonio Grassy Ceus.
Amazing guys on the board of Tesla Space X.
Really great friends with Elon Musk.
Let's say we met originally.
Yeah,
we met at then Alon must party.
How lucky were we?
The beat,
it was like,
how did they lose bracelets?
And we ended up with like,
anyway,
well especially me,
this guy,
no,
I mean pretty amazing to be there.
But anyway,
uh,
so you know,
Antonio grassiness last year my ego was flying out of control.
I want a bracelet.
And then for three months straight I was losing maybe 10 sessions.
I've never last more than three sessions that I can remember for years.
Last 10 sessions in a row,
my ego's flying out of control.
Right?
I'm more tempted than ever by these beautiful,
smart women,
you know?
And so I'm treading on this Eagle Path and I'm having fun every day,
just popping from,
I'm doing events in New York,
Chicago,
appearances.
Just like,
I just feel like,
I just feel like I felt like I was attractive then everybody and I'm just having
a blast with it,
you know?
And uh,
and I'm in the Hamptons,
you know,
and just all this fun stuff is happening and so it's leading to a little bit of
a car wreck for me.
And then Antonio grassiness asked me,
he said,
Phil,
how many bracelets would you have without your wife?
And I wanted to answer selfishly,
well,
I might have more cause I'd play more tournaments,
but I knew that wasn't true.
Yeah.
And I was like,
nine,
you said you have 14,
nine [inaudible] you really think you'd have that money without her.
And I thought,
wow,
maybe seven.
And the minute that that connected with me,
this egotistical guy walking around,
not mistreating anybody,
nice to everybody,
I've learned that,
you know,
respect everybody.
I've learned that.
Um,
but still flying high and his own like jetstream,
you know,
just kind of like thump.
Boom.
And a week later,
um,
my iPhone picture was,
I had two iPhone pictures,
one on the outside,
which was a Clinton and I,
and then the other one in the inside,
George Bush.
And I write,
so don't come at me.
I said Democrats and Republicans,
but I erased one and put my wife up and I erase the other and I put my wife and
sons up over the next two weeks.
And so I did it.
I thought,
wow,
this is the Antonio effect.
Right.
Um,
you know,
he's,
I think,
I think if Alonzo ever struggle,
which of course he never has.
I think Antonio's helped him out.
He's just been amazing.
And so just that one question just kind of,
I felt like it rerouted my life a little bit.
And then in four sessions in my home game,
I won so much money.
I won like four x what I'd lost over the last three months and I just became
more solidly entrenched in the process.
Like that was a key family first.
Then you have your fun movie star life where all these great things happened,
but family first.
And so that was significant for me.
Um,
just that question
[inaudible]
on a related note,
this is a question from Facebook,
Melanie Nelson,
what's the secret to his long lasting marriage?
So I'd just love to know,
I mean,
I'm going to tweak it a little bit,
but what other things have you done,
right?
I mean it's,
what other things have you worked on?
How have you worked on making it this long?
I mean,
it's a rarity in this world,
at least in the u s
rare,
you know,
and it hasn't,
it's not always easy,
right?
I mean,
I think one thing is that,
you know,
I still have great desire for my wife.
I still lust after honey.
I love you
and that's important to keep that,
it's important to keep that.
Um,
I think for me,
um,
you know,
I think my wife was probably ready to leave me in [inaudible] 99 like,
who the hell is this guy married a diamond in the rough,
you still in the rough,
you know,
you're still,
you're still a piece of coal.
What,
what did we were,
we were supposed to change and grow up.
You're a smart guy.
Her threatening to leave me devastated me and,
but my wife's smart,
so she didn't do anything drastic.
We went into therapy together and I worked really hard at all my faults.
Too much ego too,
self centered to narcissistic,
blah,
blah.
Right?
A lot,
a lot of stuff there was really important to work on.
And I saw the truth in all of that and I was thinking about it every week.
We'd spend an hour and a half,
two hours,
three hours a week and you know,
figuring out how things I might've done wrong to her,
mostly unintentionally.
Sometimes I'd be trying to do her a favor.
But of course,
sometimes women think differently than men.
Men are from Mars,
women are from Venus,
right?
Yup.
So I learned a lot about that stuff and it changed my primary relationship.
So I grew for a year and a half.
Massive growth.
And what I found is all the other relationships change.
One of my friends,
uh,
John Benet was crying in the car fill.
It's the first time you've listened to me and 10 years crying.
Wow.
And I was like,
that's,
that's my wife's effect.
Yeah.
You know?
So in changing the primary relationship and focusing in becoming better,
it shit,
it made me smarter and wiser in all my other relationships.
And it helped my poker too because poker is a people game.
Yeah.
And so,
so I think,
so at the end of it I was like,
well,
uh,
she made me into a better man and we ended up coming out like this.
Um,
and so I remember six months later I'm like,
man,
I missed this gross.
I want to go back into therapy just so I can get better and grow more.
And so,
I mean,
that's one thing that's,
that's been really smart for us.
And then,
you know,
I mean,
and then,
you know,
in the 30s we all know that a lot of women are leaving men and in the forties a
lot of men are leaving women.
The,
the math and the science are undisputed.
And so when I struggled a little bit with whether or not,
you know,
I wanted to be in this relationship,
I asked her to change a few things and,
uh,
we went into therapy together and she did.
And so we just keep growing.
We keep getting better and better,
better understanding of each other.
Um,
and you know,
and I think now at my age,
I'm probably safe to be with her for another 25 years.
Uh,
I know how to avoid the temptations,
you know.
Um,
and I play with fire a little bit sometimes and that I'm in those positions and
having fun.
Um,
but it,
it just like,
I just don't think after 27 years of not shading,
I'm going to go out and shape.
Yeah.
How'd your poker skills help you away from the table?
And you mentioned negotiation.
Uh,
are there any other areas in which you can think poker has helped you?
Well,
I don't know.
I have to think about that.
I mean,
maybe the answer is everything.
it couldn't be everything.
Yeah.
I mean it just,
I went to a lot of my friends who would love poker.
We're not professional players by any stretch of the imagination,
but I had one friend of mine,
very well educated guy,
I mean he has a tattoo of a semi colon.
I support very well educated guy,
John.
Uh,
who says that he learned all he needs to know about sort of navigating the world
from his learning of,
I have one.
So my friend Alan Mishra who cured tennis elbow,
I didn't say it out loud.
Well you know Allen Allen.
Yeah.
Allen is one of the foremost experts
in something called platelet rich plasma.
PRP injections.
So they take out your whole blood,
they spin it in a centrifuge and then they isolate the growth factors and then
reinject it locally into injuries.
Like tennis always been in the New York Times.
Fascinating guy.
Yeah.
That's amazing guy.
He came to me and Oh two and said,
I have this PRP thing.
Yeah.
So I got involved with them,
but really I'm like,
dude,
you're going to change the world.
And he's like,
that's just what I needed to hear.
And so I've invited my poker camps and we hang out.
And right now we're in a suicide football league together.
We have one team left,
so we're trying to decide colleague,
it's just one where you have to pick a winner each week.
Yeah.
But you can only pick a team once per year.
So by the end you're picking Cleveland and some other teams that haven't won
money games.
Got It.
Okay.
But Anyway,
um,
uh,
Alan told me that,
you know,
playing poker has helped him read his patients.
These high profile patients come to him and he says,
well,
did you hurt your knee doing this?
And if they hesitate,
it's like no transfers coming.
Like he can have you been taking your medicine the last three weeks and he can
tell whether they're lying or telling the truth.
And that's good for him because then he can design a better program for that.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Doctor,
hard to get ahold of a fundraiser.
A very,
very popular competent guy.
Well,
he's the guy that invented the,
you know,
the surgery that Colby had on the knee where I went to Germany.
Yeah.
Alan invented PRP.
Alan owns three US patents on PRP,
and yet when Colby goes over to Germany,
no one mentions Alan Mishra's name is Ian Venter.
Yeah,
it's some doctor in Germany.
Yeah.
It's amazing what he can do.
Imagine this folks,
you have your own blood.
He spins up the PRP.
Okay.
The,
the growth hormone.
Let's just say that you have Alzheimer's.
They pour the PRP and the area with Alzheimer's.
He thinks that may be one area that he can help.
Say you had a heart attack.
They've already proven that your heart will come back 85% better with your own
blood.
So imagine we've been searching the top of the Himalayas for amazing things when
it's inside your blood.
All this ability to cure and a,
and Alan's working on some curing cancer stuff.
Uh,
which is amazing.
And I,
I don't know.
I,
I dunno,
maybe I'm naive.
I believe he has a decent shot to,
I believe he's going to cure cancer.
Let me just,
this,
this small world story.
I mean,
it's worth pointing out.
I'm not originally from the bay area.
You're not originally from the bay area.
Uh,
I got advice very early on.
This is on my answering machine,
actually way back in the day from a mentor.
And he said,
you're the average of the five people you associate with most.
I was like,
Huh.
And that's been one of the pieces of advices,
guided a lot of my decisions,
one of which was where to move to live.
So the bay area,
you just happened to bump into people like telling mushroom and it's amazing.
Ah,
when you hear the word,
he's a crazy guy.
He just said,
hey,
he just went to the Nobel prize winners and said,
Hey,
uh,
I have a new concept.
You know how we're trying to starve cancer cells?
I'm just going to feed them platelet rich plasma and see how that works.
You know?
So there's been some progress,
so I'll probably sound stupid do you can keep this in,
but I'll probably sound stupid saying he's going to,
I think he's going to cure cancer,
but I'm sticking by it.
Eh,
he certainly cure a lot of other stuff,
so yeah,
he's a brilliant guy.
No one knows his name.
Those true.
When you hear the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind for you and why?
Wow.
I mean,
I think of,
I think of some of my best friends,
I think of Chamath Palihapitiya.
I think a Billy and people don't really,
unless you're a business insider or you haven't heard of these guys,
can you explain why?
Is that what you're thinking?
You're thinking what Elon Musk done is beyond success,
what he's doing,
you know,
he thinks we live in a matrix.
You know,
he,
he sending people to Mars,
he has Tesla,
he has basic cs.
That's extraordinary.
And I'm
sorry,
I was thinking Chamath Palihapitiya and Millie,
the wire,
these two very famous investors at this point.
Again,
nobody in the room knows her name.
So why are they,
what makes them successful to you?
Well,
the thing I like about thing,
I define success a little differently.
So Chamath,
um,
I mean I tease him that he got lucky.
He didn't want to go to Facebook.
They just kept giving him more and more stock.
He's like,
I don't know if this thing's going to work.
So finally it took the stock and went,
so,
you know,
each point is worth,
what,
2 billion.
Now?
He's done pretty well.
So,
but it's what he's done.
He plays poker great.
He,
his family's great.
He has an amazing wife,
Bridget,
and three young children.
And I see the effort that he puts into like,
you know,
they used to as a lot of people in Silicon Valley,
the three nannies,
the maids,
all that kind of stuff.
And these guys have gone a little bit away from that.
Um,
and chammas he's been cooking meals for his wife and kids a little bit,
which I've never done,
but it's amazing to me.
He's put family first.
Yeah.
And yet still change the world,
you know,
uh,
deployed billions,
one point $2 billion now out into the field.
He's crushing it.
Right.
Um,
and then I looked at my friend Billy,
who,
you know,
spends a fair amount of time in his backyard with his young kids and,
uh,
and you know,
deals come to him.
As you know,
he's really good friends with Elon Musk.
And I think when alarm flies over to Paris to do a climate change,
there's one other guy on the plane.
It's bill and bill because bill is brilliant and you want bill with you cause
bill is going to help you write your climate speech,
you know,
um,
when the gigafactory opens,
he want Billy next to,
you know.
And so these guys,
um,
they're living,
they're having a really nice lives and bill is one of the best angel investors
in history.
Yeah.
Maybe the best angel investor in history,
we don't know,
but he's been involved with,
but he sits in his backyard and I'll go,
I,
what was it two days ago I went and we had lunch together and we had a drink and
just kind of chill,
you know,
and that's,
and I'll go to his house once a week and spend four hours in the afternoon
sitting in the backyard.
He has,
you know,
a one year old and a three year old and a six year old and they're coming by,
always spicing up the atmosphere.
And it just,
I enjoy that.
I enjoy the,
the friendship thing.
I didn't get that.
I didn't get that until 2010 I was all about poker and family.
And then I just,
I kind of realize it's seeped into my life.
The importance of strong friendships.
Definitely.
So
there's a concept of forgiveness that's hugely important.
And so for me personally,
when I was studying Buddhism,
um,
and we spent a week at Iceland,
Kathy and I,
my wife and I,
a week at epsilon,
we weren't allowed to talk Aslin for those guys who don't know if this sort of
idyllic spot in big Sur [inaudible] like spiritual place that was famous from
the 60s has natural hot springs and it's really fun.
And so when I studied Buddhism,
the concept of forgiveness was important.
I had someone steal $28,000 from me.
Now understand
I was staking this guy.
I was feeding his family of that $28,000 that he had online that he stole from
me.
14,000 was his only to do is call me and say,
Phil,
I need 7,000 you take 7,000 will 14,000 on.
Instead,
he chose to steal 28,000 from me when I got the phone call.
But this has happened.
I said,
what happened?
And I was in shock.
This guy just stole 28,000 from me.
I'm sending money to his family,
I'm staking them.
What's going on here?
And uh,
and I called my friend John Benetti Ben,
he's like fry em.
Really see evidence,
crush him,
destroy him for life.
We had the evidence,
neat pile of evidence released on the Internet.
He's destroyed for life.
But what good does that to me?
Yup.
What good.
And so I was just furious and steaming and whatever.
And I called the guy and he was crying on the phone and I finally just decided,
honey,
you and I are going out to dinner.
We're going to have the most expensive dinner and the most expensive bottle of
wine I can have because my life is amazing.
And I've spent one hour or two hours of my time steaming cause someone stole
from me.
We went out,
we had a really nice dinner.
At the end of that dinner,
I said,
I'm going to completely forgive the guy.
Nothing was ever released,
but here's some beauty.
Here's what I didn't expect.
I got paid back in full.
This guide defends me to everybody on the planet.
My wife said he's turned into a like a protector of yours.
So now there's a big profile guy.
He's defending me to everybody telling everybody what a great guy I am.
And I remember the other amazing thing about this.
This happened on a Monday night.
I could've released it all hell breaks loose.
The Internet just goes crazy in the poker world.
Instead,
I flew to Connecticut to playing a poker tournament.
$10,000 buy in on Friday.
You can't make this up.
You can't.
I saw the guy walked out on me in the hallway.
I shook his hand.
It hurt a little bit.
It hurt a little bit,
but I shook his hand.
I wouldn't give him a hug.
I've shook his hand,
but I never had to worry about him again after shaking his hand.
Right.
Yup.
And this is the freaky thing.
I played in that tournament.
Now if I were at war with him and I don't know,
he couldn't say anything negative about me,
but he might just start throwing mud,
trying to come up with stuff.
Right.
I Dunno.
He couldn't,
he could never attack me.
Right.
But people would make shit up.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
so rather than in some mud throwing contest,
my mind is focused on the poker tournament.
You can't make,
I can't just,
I want $280,000.
No
preferred place.
280,000 exactly 10 times.
What?
You lost what had been stolen from me.
So I got the 280,000.
The guy paid me back and full and he's been a protector of mine all cause I
forgave this really bad act.
Bad Actor Act.
Yeah.
Right.
So I love the concept,
I forget was this isn't the only time I have another great forgiveness story.
In fact,
I'm going to tell it because if anything makes us edit,
I want the forgiveness stuff to make the edit.
Okay.
Another guy who I used to play poker with and the eighties I'm in Madison,
Wisconsin.
He made sure that I was banned from the big game.
He didn't want me to play in the big game in Madison.
He banned me.
So it was a lot of animosity towards him rise.
He afraid of losing or why didn't even what you've play?
Partly that probably thought I was acting up a little bit,
but I think it was mostly didn't want me in the game because I was winning so
much money in Madison.
He banned me for three years.
I moved in 1993 and 1994 I saw him with some other friends that I invited them
out to a movie.
We went out to a dinner and a movie and that was nice as I could be and I
completely forgave him.
Okay.
In your head or in my head,
and sometimes that's an act where a lie down on a bed.
I'll close my eyes and I'll try to meditate and I'll send love towards that
person that I hate.
I'll just waves of love,
whatever that means to the individual.
But when I'm doing that,
I usually am on the bed a long time.
Cause then I'm like,
well I have to send love to all the people I love to.
Yeah.
So
they're 20 minutes,
but I don't know,
I can't explain it to you.
Then the very next time I see someone like that who have sent love too,
it's like they've received it.
So did they just notice that my demeanor towards some change,
that I'm happy to see them or what happened?
I don't know.
I can't explain it.
So what,
how would this guy,
so this guy calls me three years later and led me to and said,
hey listen,
I recommended you for this deal and I made like $14 million.
[inaudible]
so I gotta Tell Ya,
I'm into forgiveness.
So I forgive everybody.
So now,
but I haven't had,
I haven't had some of the really horrible stuff happened.
You know,
like I don't know,
rape or stuff like that.
I don't,
I wouldn't know how to counsel someone.
Just really traumatic stuff happened,
you know?
But I know for me,
forgiving people stealing from me and all this other stuff has led to amazing
results and I have no hatred in my heart.
I get to walk around happy everyday,
you know?
And again,
I think it's really huge.
I'll say it again.
When you're walking down any hallway in,
anybody in the planet walks towards you,
I don't have to turn left or right.
[inaudible]
I think it's also,
uh,
you know,
I remember thinking to myself at one point that beat if you're offended easily
because I am offended easily.
I have some anger issues.
Sometimes you're a bad resource allocator.
It's a bad use of this finite resource wishes your energy and calories and hours
on this planet when you're awake.
So for me it's like,
all right,
well it's kind of a two for one.
If you forgive people,
you get the altruism,
but you also got the practicality and then you get these unforeseen ripple
effects later.
I wasn't expecting
the ripple effects,
but it happens.
It's just wonderful.
I'm like,
wow,
this is this something I'm going to do the rest of my life.
Um,
I've had guys,
like,
right,
80 negative blogs about me.
It's about the way I play poker.
Never cross the line to personal,
maybe a little bit in there and forgave those guys.
And I knew this guy who attacked me all this time that actually kind of loved
me.
So I forgave him and we moved on and we're friends.
So I've never written a red,
I've never written anything negative about him ever.
But it's okay.
Yeah,
I don't feel the need to,
you know.
So I want to maybe take a hard left turn and talk about turning away from
forgiveness to rampage from forgiveness to ram fit.
Don't worry,
we're not going to end on a sour.
They knew at that rate.
We're not going to end on a sour note.
So you told the story last night.
Well,
I was having some mall back,
let's be honest.
And uh,
you told the ongoing on the rampage story,
now it was,
was this in Europe or was it somewhere else?
So then we had a $300,000 buy in tournament in May and a,
and I decided there was a 300 k there was another hundred k another hundred k.
And so I thought,
you know what,
I've been bad at raising money to play poker.
I have let one guy stake me,
I've made them like 1.5 million.
It's been great,
but let me try this other way.
And so I reached out to my friends,
but I wasn't sure they would respond.
So I reached out.
So I thought,
but I only want to reach out once.
So in this email I'm going to list,
I'm gonna say the first thing,
it's a high risk investment.
You're putting up $540,000 for me to play six tournaments,
high risk.
So be aware you probably going to lose your money.
That's how I led the email and then a,
and then I said I listed the events when they would be on television because
it's kind of fun when you're sticking someone to watch them live on television,
they're playing your money,
you're live on television.
Like,
that's my horse man.
I mean that's like better than having somebody in the Kentucky Derby.
The derby only lasts 60 seconds.
You,
they got to watch me play.
If you'd like to be nervous for hours,
they get to watch me.
Yes,
they got to watch me play 20 hours of live television in this event or more than
that.
And so it's kind of cool.
So I sent it out and I also put wiring instructions and I said,
let's see what happens.
$540,000 so I'll take,
I'll take a 10% free roll and I'll put in the first 54,000 that way I'm playing
for 20%.
All right,
let's see what happens.
Well,
within 20 hours I sold up and then people were mad at me cause I didn't get him
in.
So,
um,
so now I'm playing this $300,000 buy in tournament and it's live on Fox sports
net and we're,
we're on day two or whatever.
I think it's sold out at 48 players.
We're on day two,
it's late and maybe even day three and I'm feeling boxed in.
What does that mean?
I have a young,
great player on my right.
Dan Smith,
another great player,
fader Holtz on my left who's been crushing it in 2016 just crushing it and
there's somebody else there and I just felt like they're onto me.
They're playing me too well.
And I said,
screw this.
I might bust myself,
but I'm going to try something else.
I said,
this is it that they're just there to attuned to me.
Well,
they've also have years of tape on your correct.
So I said,
I'm on a rampage,
raise it,
and I'm throwing the chips in and I'm saying I'm on a rampage.
Like once every 15 seconds I'm on a rampage.
I'm Amanda.
I raised 10 pots in a row and they were like from being this calm patient fill
to all of a sudden raising.
And they're just like,
I just saw the looks on their faces.
What the Hell is going on here?
Raise it,
raise it,
raise it.
Well,
the whole cards are flushing to the world.
Nine deuce off suit,
Jack four off suit,
you know,
seven do soft suit.
Just nothing.
I'm not even looking at my hands.
I didn't even look at a hand during my rampage.
Raise it,
raise it,
raise it.
I'm on a rampage.
I'm winning every pot accumulating all these chips.
And I'm like,
all right.
I messed up their flow.
Right.
And um,
and if they do call and bedding,
the flop,
a bedding,
the turn firing,
just throwing chips in there.
And I'm saying,
I'm on a rampage.
It was great television.
I'm sure two things happened.
One,
I'm finally in the big blind.
All the backers are like my horses on a rampage.
Well,
yeah.
Oh,
I got those emails the next day.
Trust me.
So now I'm in the big blind.
I hadn't looked at my whole cards.
There's a guy in the small blind and I said,
I'm on a rampage.
Everybody else had fold.
They don't dare raise my blind.
He's like,
all in,
he puts 2 million in.
I looked on a queens,
I call 700,000 he has a nine and a 10 I owned that point.
I'm at 1.4 million and I'm on a rampage.
And I'm on a rampage.
I'm going on and on about it.
And finally,
finally I slowed down.
Now the next day,
so I did this.
No one understands on the planet why I did this.
This is one reason why I'm a bad poker player.
They say,
right?
What I'm trying to do is just lose my mind,
be crazy and let them know you're not bluffing me for this next 20 hands.
You are not going to bluff me.
You might beat me,
but if you raise me,
I'm calling all your rear raises too.
I'm telling them,
you reraise me,
I'm calling,
so let's just get it on.
You know,
I don't,
it just doesn't matter to me.
It's all threatened bluster.
And I probably would've called them if they reraise me because that's just what
I was going to do,
you know?
And so,
but it really changed the dynamics of the game.
Now,
of course,
the next day I had like five different investors emailing me.
Phil,
don't lose it like that again.
Fill.
What were you thinking,
Phil?
What are you doing?
Why are you playing nine too soft too?
Why are you playing Jack Three off suit?
You know all of these commentary,
you know,
and I'm just like,
I'm like,
doesn't anybody see the brilliance of what I did
know?
They see the insanity of what I just did.
One in the same,
right?
It's like everyone has a plan until they get punched in the face.
Custom auto
trader.
My tasks.
You have a pretty theory now let me go on a rampage.
So we're going to wrap up with some of the,
by the way,
some of them,
some of the highest ratings ever in poker history.
Yeah,
I mean,
no,
sure.
I mean to watch me go crazy like that.
Those clips have been watched just a ton.
It isn't gentlemen,
Phil,
you
[inaudible].
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoyed this podcast is brought to you by Mizzen and main,
many of you,
long time listeners know how I feel about visiting Maine.
They make you most comfortable dress shirts in the world.
Quite possibly.
They use advanced performance fabrics,
which provides stretch and comfort,
but that's not the real selling point to me.
That's all great.
It's all really good,
but they are the only dress shirts,
so to speak,
that I travel with because you don't have to iron them and we're steaming no
more headache.
I can just punch them up,
throw them in a bag,
pull them out,
and no one will be the wiser.
They're fancy enough for important dinners,
but made from athletics,
sweat wicking material so they're all purpose.
And hundreds of pro athletes love these shirts,
including NFL opera,
Jj Watt,
and last time these guys were on the show.
They sold out of every item.
They feature every single skew.
So if you're interested in getting a shirt and might want to check them out on
the faster side,
just go to tim.blog four slash shirts and you can receive $50 off when you
purchase three or more shirts.
So check it out.
tim.blog/shirts this episode is brought to you by movement watches and that is
spelled M v empty movement watches.
I first became aware of this company back in 2014 when there are brand,
brand new,
maybe company because they won first place in Shopify,
build a business competition.
The founders are two college dropouts who wanted to wear fancy watches but had
whoa wee little problem.
They couldn't afford fancy watches so they decided to scratch their own itch.
Since then,
they're high quality affordable watches have gone from startup to more than 1
million watches sold across 160 countries.
It's an awesome success story and when you check out the product,
you'll know why they offer classic design,
quality construction and many different modern styles,
so you can really pick one that suits you.
You might want to start one.
I would suggest probably appeal to a lot of folks out there as the classic black
silver,
so search classic white silver.
The guys that movement have a great offer for listeners to this podcast.
They're offering 15% off your entire purchase with free shipping and free
returns.
If you're dissatisfied for any reason,
and they are very,
very famous for their customer support,
just visit movement,
watches.com/tim that's m v m t watches.com forward slash Tim.